[Música]
os voy a contar uno de los capítulos de
la historia reciente del mundo
empresarial pero antes miremos por un
momento al pasado
tras la primera guerra mundial con un
conflicto nadie esperaba una especie de
huida hacia adelante desde adueñó de
gran parte de la sociedad una nueva
época nazi a un mundo nuevo que nada
tenía que ver con la anterior una época
de prosperidad económica que llegó a ser
conocida como los felices años 20
y tras la segunda guerra mundial los
gloriosos treinta las tres décadas de
oro del capitalismo que acabaron con la
crisis del petróleo de 1973
y la historia es cíclica así que en este
momento conviene reflexionar
si este virus que nos rodea cambiará
nuestras vidas y sobre todo si cambiara
el mundo de forma definitiva
ya que se están perturbando los
parámetros económicos sociales y
culturales
y los efectos de su devastadora
presencia son notorios y conviene
conviene pensar hacia dónde vamos aún
así este último tiempo lo recordaremos
con un momento inolvidable en nuestras
vidas un tiempo en que nuestro mundo
cambio son tantas las transformaciones
que estamos viviendo y a la velocidad a
las que se están produciendo que en
ocasiones tenemos la impresión de estar
viendo una buena o mala película de
ciencia ficción verdad
cuánto y cómo han cambiado las
situaciones las formas las personas las
instituciones las acciones
la economía global la educación el
mercado y la forma de trabajo la pérdida
de empleos algunas profesiones los
hábitos de consumo y socialización
el diseño urbano la industria de la
salud los ignorados y subvalorados
recovecos de nuestra sociedad
el incremento de la violencia doméstica
el capitalismo de la vigilancia
y los propósitos de las instituciones de
las personas
el sinfín de la seic news la
desaparición de los espectáculos de
masas las tasas de morbilidad y
mortalidad
el retorno a lo rural la emergencia más
profunda del medio ambiente la
amplificación de las desigualdades
y la buena vecindad
y el regreso a la vida normal implica un
desgaste emocional para muchas personas
personas que sufren de ansiedad y
depresión
mujeres inmersas en relaciones violentas
niños que experimentan abuso o abandono
a manos de sus padres personas que
sufren la pérdida de un ser querido
víctima del contagio
todos ellos se han llevado la peor parte
y sus experiencias podrían tener
consecuencias en sus relaciones
personales que no desaparecerán
mágicamente con una vacuna y eso sin
contar con la tensión añadida de los
graves problemas económicos que muchas
personas se verán obligadas a soportar
[Música]
precisamente esas dificultades
económicas son las que ejercerán presión
a los vínculos sociales y como sociedad
si como sociedad necesitaremos mucho más
que anticuerpos para recuperarnos
este virus es un acelerador de la
transformación digital los desafíos que
está presentando esta crisis brindan una
oportunidad para que las instituciones
evolucionen a una nueva realidad donde
predomina lo digital
aunque esta pandemia ha puesto de
manifiesto hasta qué punto la
interacción digital no sustituye a la
real de hecho se ha convertido en un
instrumento de medición para saber cuán
preparados estábamos a nivel privado y
público en la ruta de la transformación
digital aunque las respuestas a los
retos de la pandemia no estén solo en la
tecnología sino también en lo humano y
lo social
estamos viviendo el mayor shock para las
empresas en el último siglo muchas
pequeñas y medianas empresas se están
quedando sin efectivo y terminan
cerrando los compradores reconsiderar
sus hábitos y prioridades la
transformación digital de los negocios
es más rápida con más automatización e
inteligencia artificial las cadenas de
suministro son más cortas más
resistentes y más locales el mercado de
la aviación es más pequeño y esto
significa que viajaremos menos porque
los precios de los billetes subirán
el futuro del trabajo se acelera y
enfrenta a muchos desafíos la enseñanza
se ha trasladado online a una escala
jamás vista pero también nos enfrentamos
a la pobreza digital que está marginando
a algunos niños que no disponen de
herramientas tecnológicas para formarse
el futuro de los deportes también se
presenta muy diferente el
distanciamiento social es un enorme
dolor de cabeza para esas instituciones
pero
qué cambios han llegado para quedarse
y cuáles se revertirán en el momento en
el que se vuelva a la normalidad
cómo será el día a día para las empresas
más allá del cobi 19
y bueno pues parece que el diseño de la
organización y la cultura organizacional
del futuro se vislumbra como un ente con
unos clientes del tipo de 360 unos
clientes concebidos desde una
perspectiva global un estilo de
liderazgo digital y disruptivo unos
nuevos modelos de negocio teletrabajar
les el trabajo a tiempo completo o bien
en fórmulas mixtas aunque surgen riesgos
psicosociales o económicos asociados al
uso de las tecnologías y la
individualidad de la persona trabajadora
que habrá que abordar
una organización flexible y colaborativa
enfocada en la responsabilidad social
corporativa el impulso de la
conciliación de la vida laboral a través
de los nuevos planes de igualdad es ya
una constante en este sentido surgen
también profesiones digitales o ligadas
a la estrategia de transformación
digital y en este nuevo escenario
se propiciará el incremento paulatino de
la capacitación digital para el
teletrabajo y la vida diaria el aumento
de la cultura digital de las personas la
colaboración en entornos de trabajo
flexibles la institucionalización de la
transformación digital la capacidad de
desarrollo de nuevos modelos de negocios
sostenibles y digitales ahora
pensemos que este último capítulo de la
historia del mundo empresarial tendrá un
final prometedor
con la mirada en un futuro esperanzado y
la celeridad con que la comunidad
científica global ha reaccionado
aparcando sus proyectos para abordar
esta crisis sanitaria los investigadores
han creado vacunas en un plazo que
parecía imposible
uno de los mayores éxitos de la historia
de la ciencia
el haber acortado a menos de un año lo
que normalmente lleva de media una
década constituye por unanimidad el hito
del 2020 según la prestigiosa revista
science
procesos personas y tecnología tres
pilares sobre los que se deberían
sostener todos los retos y cambios a los
que se enfrenta el mundo empresarial
ahora
os invito a que cierre los ojos
[Música]
conviene señor
quienes de vosotros no tiene ganas de
irse de fiesta a hacer un viaje
darse
[Música]
un paseo tomas una bebida en una terraza
hacen las dichosas mascarillas
y si todo va bien nos vacunaremos y
veremos como una explosión de fiestas y
celebraciones en las calles los montes
en las playas este virus
un apocalíptico como esperanzador ha
cambiado el mundo empresarial y nuestras
vidas pero sólo en parte
una avenida para quedarse
[Música]
[Aplausos]